[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after nine rounds of heart-stopping
action the fifth edition of the
Sinquefield club ended in a convincing
victory for the pride of France
Maxime Vasily grave was critical win in
the all-important final round pulled him
away from the rest of the pack the best
players in the world recalled us with
their deep opening preparation created
middle game ideas contentious end games
and overall daring play this epic
tournament will go down as one to
remember as his reputation continues to
grow as one of the greatest events in
all of chess hello everyone and welcome
to the closing ceremony of the 2017
Sinquefield Cup here in st. Louis the
capital of chess in the United States
I'm Maurice Ashley and I'm honored to be
here among these great players
dignitaries friends and fans of the
Chess Club
it was a spectacular event this year
absolutely great play by the players
they had incredible fighting spirit they
showed great they showed toughness and
most of all they showed class and so it
is our pleasure to introduce you to our
closing ceremony before we go any
further I would like to thank two people
who without them there would be no
Sinquefield Cup there would be no Chess
Club and scholastic Center of st. Louis
and it wouldn't be a resurgence of chess
in the United States please give a big
hand everyone to dr. Jeanne Singh field
and Rex Sinquefield
[Applause]
now we all have to say that one of the
great things about this event is the
fact that it's broadcasted so well and
they have hired the best absolutely
great teams we want to thank Randy
Sinquefield of spectrum studios and Tom
Wilkinson
and his team at silverback because
without them we don't look so good and
we appreciate everything they've done to
really take chess broadcasting to the
very highest level I also want to thank
fleischman-hillard who was in charge of
all the media in this event and of
course we want to thank a special group
and those are the commentators and we
had a crackerjack team Rex likes to call
us the best in the world a little bit of
hyperbole Rex is used to engaging in
hyperbole but we thank him and
appreciate that and first I'd like to
thank some of the commentators that
worked with us first of all from the
Spanish broadcast grandmaster Alejandro
Ramirez and women's international master
event Garcia please give them a hand we
also had our own Grandmaster roving very
master who also had his special Coaches
Corner
counts corner Cathy I forget Romanian
yes as a connection please thank you
very much - Christian charla Grandmaster
Christian trailer
we had other commentators as well
working the show we had Eric Hansen I
believe is not here anymore grandmas
Eric Hansen and also Grandmaster version
a Cobian we had other assistance as well
women's Grandmaster working for the
working as a journalist for the event
woman's Grandmaster Tata Abraham Yan we
also had a new member of the team
working with the Spanish broadcast
international master dorsa Derek Shani
and these two my partners in crime we
absolutely had a lot of fun people say
we have chemistry is because we actually
like each other my honor my special
honor to introduce the superfriends
Grandmaster yasss Irwin and women's
Grand Master Jennifer Shahade II big
hand ladies
now the grand chest tour is a big vision
it was a big vision by big visionaries
it's important of course Rex and Jeanne
had their vision but also we had
partners in this one garry kasparov who
is conspicuously absent today I don't
know where Gary is but we also had other
partners as well the chess promotions
limited from London Malcolm Payne who
was the organizer of the London event
and he definitely is one of those that
we'd like to thank as well
now the organizers that the event is
held in many stages this year it's five
stages we had in the Paris leg Colliers
International Vivendi and dailymotion on
the levant leg your next move here of
course a Sinquefield cup is reck Seng
feel and the st. Louis chess club as
well as the new member of this amazing
tournament series the rapid and blitz
which will start in just a couple of
days and finally the London chess
classic which will happen in December
and as a for mention Malcolm Payne
organized all right well I have the
special honor now that that is out the
way of introducing a woman who keeps Rex
in check that is hard to do let me tell
you but she does it with style with
grace I'd like to welcome dr. Jeanne
Singh field
[Applause]
and we do have two we do have to mention
Maurice as the third of the parties in
crime now for those of you who have been
here for the very beginning the first
year is just the sink filled cup and Rex
did not want it to be named the same
feel Cup and I would like to thank all
the people who are already here who have
won in the past Magnus Carlsen year one
ba-ba-ba-ba one Okara 1o year 2 which is
wonderful
seven year Levon Aronian and Wesley so
[Applause]
and I won't mention the fifth one
because it's gonna be a surprise so my
job is to introduce Rex
so this tournament is named after thanks
sing feel Cup here you go
[Applause]
is this on yes it is well you know
Shakespeare said that parting is such
sweet sorrow and all rightie was in this
tournament comes to a close I get
homesick for it
we celebrate the tournament at the end
of it but things have to go and we have
to say goodbye to these incredible chess
players and great friends and I'm gonna
repeat some of the thanks because they
deserve it certainly Randi and all of
his crew and it is not hyperbole to say
the Jennifer Yasir and Maurice are the
best commentators of any sport in the
world it is a statement of utmost
accuracy
and thanks also again to all of our live
commentators doing the the Spanish
broadcast over a kingside diner and
Alejandro and a vet var and Eric etc all
of you make this really exciting and
it's interesting to see that we get
bigger crowds every year the grand
chests tour is working around the 2018
calendar to expand the tour and when we
know the answers we will share them with
you so with this I will turn it over to
one of the three great chess
commentators in the world Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley well before we continue
let's first acknowledge these great
players these great geniuses of our time
without which you would have no
branches' tour without which we wouldn't
be so entertained by their fighting
spirit I'd like to just acknowledge each
and every one of them as they have come
from far and wide they have prepared
immensely for this battle some one has
to win some one has to be not so great
but they're all gentlemen and it was an
absolute pleasure to watch you players
I'm a fan I consider myself one of the
bigger fans being able to follow you
guys and watch you play it's just such a
special treat I can tell you the
commentators feel like we can't believe
we have this job and it's because of
gentlemen like yourselves so first I'll
call your name please stand and
acknowledge the crowd from the United
States Grand Master Wesley so
from Russia Grandmaster Yanni upon the
achi Armenia Levon Aronian also from
Russia Peter Svidler
[Applause]
from India
Vishwanath on-on-on from Norway magnus
carlsen from the United States Fabiano
caruana also from the United States
Hikaru Nakamura from Russia Sergey
Karjakin
[Applause]
and I think there's someone I forgot
from France Maxime vasila grog
[Applause]
whenever we do these ceremonies we
always forget someone there's someone
sitting very special person you're
sitting at stage he is a personal
advisor to Garry Kasparov
as well as a member of the board of the
grand Chester and his work has been
truly seminal and being able to support
this event I'd like to introduce also
Michael cutter cough Sookie we hired a
new technical director of this year
Graham Jorgenson of South Africa who did
quite a bit of work I'm sure he's
watching live online right now so Thank
You Graham wherever you are we know you
keep plugging away at all the rules and
all the niceties and details that we
need I'd like to now introduce the
winners the top players in the event
this player went through the entire
event undefeated
he was at plus-2 played one of the most
brilliant games of the event may be the
most brilliant game of the event and as
always continues to show how incredible
he is at staying current with the game I
know he hates to hear that he's the
elder statesman but today I was in the
gym and guess it was the only other
player I saw in the gym it was this
gentleman he stays fit he's still a
marvelous champion five-time world
champion tying for a second place
Vishwanath on-on-on
rats would you stand with them
[Applause]
the photos another magnificent champion
I mean his name says it all he always
looks to win every single event he plays
he actually won the first two legs off
the grand chest tour in total style came
just a little short but for a few moves
in this competition we'd be calling him
the runaway win over the grand chesta
tour but as usual he picked himself up
dusted himself off and when it mattered
in the last round one as he needed to
please acknowledge our reigning world
champion Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
and I will hand the microphone over to
Rex for a special introduction of our
winner Thank You Maurice you know it was
almost 200 years ago in 1821 that Louie
Charles mob de la Bourdonnais became the
strongest chess player in the world he
kept his position as the best player
until his death in 1840 laborda nee was
considered one of the uncrowned kings of
chess our unofficial world champion
since there was no official championship
tournament to be held until 1886 and I'm
happy to say that some of those games
were played right here in st. Louis so
it's been 200 years since l'avorton a
made his mark and now we have French
Grandmaster Maxime Vasya le rêve become
the world's number two rated player by
winning the 2017 Sinquefield Cup one of
the strongest tournaments of the year
Maxime is just a short distance behind
the reigning world champion Magnus
Carlsen
who is in the lead for the 2017 grand
Chester and the ultimate winner of this
tour will be decided by the last leg in
London and who knows maybe one day we
will see the ultimate challenge of the
chess crown the World Championship
Grandmaster magnus carlsen against
Maxime Varela Grove it is my pleasure to
recognize and to invite up here the
winner of the 2017 Sinquefield Cup
Maxime beshear magrav
[Applause]
Wow Maxime collects his championship
trophy there two trophies there one
Maxime gets to take home and one which
stays with the Chess Club he is the
fifth unique winner of this event we've
had five tournaments so far and no one
has repeated as a winner of the event
pretty incredible just shows how tough
it is to win this one time much less to
win it twice so Maxime the pride of
France he made a special claim that he
did not he really wanted to win this
event he did not want to go away without
the title because in fact he had not won
a super tournament elite tournament by
himself and this time he has
accomplished his dream makes him please
congratulations and please give us a few
remarks
I mean there's many things I have to
address and the first of them will go to
Janie and wax for the amazing work
they're putting up and to you know to
bring this chess tournament and I think
centrist is more than the sink filled
cup I mean just so much going on in in
San Chris and you know the club is
expanding the fame and I think it goes
to show such dedication to to bring
chest to Zona to the highest levels also
of course is a good staff was you know
at our service for the for the last
week's and every time we come here so
stuff other clubs over Fame everyone
working to make this event possible and
of GREs stand-ups of course the players
I think this year we had an event of
hoody
I mean that was extremely tense because
before the restaurant five players could
could actually cream the title and in
general the games were or art fault and
some of them were really quite however
and I loved playing these events I love
a challenge and I think everyone here of
the challenge and know for small
personal thanks because I think I need
to acknowledge you know the the work for
first of all that my seconds put up for
me to to be able to to challenge
everyone in this field in the openings
and I think it went beyond my
expectations
I'd like to thank my family because
you know so he supports me for the best
part of my 26 years of age and you know
it's impossible to achieve whatever
I'm at right now without there and I'd
like to thank my friends who support
supporting me throughout the event you
know I mean I was not waiting in touch
with them I mean no I was in touch with
them that they were they well not here
I'm in my my French colleagues and you
know we would keep in touch via Skype or
Facebook and you know it encouraged me
you know even when you're tired by the
end of the event you just want to show
them your gratitude by giving your best
in the last games and I think that made
all the difference and I'm sure I'm
forgetting some persons you know yeah of
course you know there were the people
who supported me for the event also
congratulate Tamia at the end and you
know I received so many messages I was
too lazy to answer all of them but I'll
try to do that for being in the plane
tomorrow that sounds like a good time to
do that and that's not good but of
course I also have to thank her because
he picked me as we know the event
so thanks to mr. you you should support
you shot great vision and that that I
didn't expect from you but pleasantly
surprised
the pride of France once again ladies
and gentlemen grandmaster maxim bachelor
ground well as as maxim said of course
you forget people who were involved in
this event and all the support we get
here from this amazing place it wouldn't
happen without the leadership of tony
rich pig-dog executive director and it's
certainly joy brave I'm sure is hiding
somewhere
come on joy come on acknowledge it yes
and her incredible team we are in
absolute austere surroundings this
wonderful place epic place the world
chess Hall of Fame the great players
here on these walls and these players of
course will very shortly grace those
walls as well they have a long career
ahead so they're not thinking about that
right now
but they are already legends of this
game well there's another event that
will be taking place in a couple of days
a few players here will not be playing
in it Magnus Carlsen has already played
and won two events max in viola Grove
who is hot on his heels has also played
two events in Wesley soul has also
played two events there come a wild card
players here will will depart as friends
as always no Peter Svidler who played
wonderfully this event in the end won a
big game in the last round young Napalm
the achi you're here still right you're
here still okay
make sure forget it yeah no we want you
to spare we want you to stay and it
looks like everybody else is gonna stay
with us
sorry that's right right yeah so
everybody else is going to
here and then there's gonna be one
interloper
we'll call him his name is Gary Kasparov
and he will join us as well and you
don't want to miss that event it's going
to start of course on the 14th and we
will have tremendous excitement around
Gary's return to the game even if it's
only he calls it a one-off I'm not sure
I believe him but he will certainly be
fighting for the highest title here and
it'll be a lot of fun we will keep on
the edges of our seats as we do
commentary for that as well it will be
wrapping a blitz beginning at 12:50 the
show on perfectly central 150 Eastern
right here in st. Louis well thank you
everyone that event will of course be
concluded the whole tour in London so
we'll look forward to that but right now
we will say thank you here from st.
Louis it was a spectacular event as
Maxime said five players could have won
in the end but one had to emerge the
champion we appreciate your fans support
and we continue to try to provide you
with the best kind of best kind of
broadcast that we can we are humbled by
your graciousness thank you everyone
have a great night and goodbye from st.
Louis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]